Jake:这一个
Jake: This one.
Jake:一个插头是吧
Jake: A plug, right?
Shure: 是的然后咱们弄几个锅
Shure: Yes, and then let's get some pots.
Shure: 是弄一个锅还是两个锅
Shure: Should we get one pot or two pots?
Shure: 杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Shure: 一个锅
Shure: One pot.
Jake:有两个锅
Jake: We have two pots.
Shure: 对有两
Shure: Yeah, two.
Jake:这个不用垫
Jake: This one doesn't need electricity.
Lucia: 他们居然真的有运动过这个房子
Lucia: They actually moved this house.
Shure: 个锅那就用一个这个吧先
Shure: Then let's use this one first.
Shure: 用两个锅
Shure: Use two pots.
Jake:一个不用电
Jake: One doesn't need electricity.
Jake:就一个用电
Jake: Just one needs electricity.
Shure: 底下还有一个不用电的
Shure: There's another one that doesn't need electricity underneath.
Jake:咱没那么多差异
Jake: We don't have that many differences.
Alice: 太短了
Alice: Too short.
Shure: 这气好像不是那么多问题
Shure: The gas doesn't seem to be much of an issue.
Shure: 应该也不大
Shure: Shouldn't be a big deal.
Jake:这个是
Jake: This is...
Lucia: 冰箱的电源吗
Lucia: Is this the refrigerator's power?
Jake:可以用对
Jake: Yes, you can use it.
Jake:但是插墙上就行
Jake: But just plug it into the wall.
Lucia: 你在这边
Lucia: You over here.
Lucia: 我拿上来了
Lucia: I brought it up.
Jake:看一看还有看还有多少
Jake: Check to see how much is left.
Alice:这个叉子
Alice: This fork.
Shure: 这个插座上面
Shure: This outlet.
Alice:上面插排插插排插排插插排
Alice: Plug in the power strip, the power strip, the power strip, the power strip.
Shure: 对这个插座上面
Shure: Yes, this outlet.
Alice:会不会有安全隐患
Alice: Could it be a safety hazard?
Shure: 没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Lucia: 不会不会
Lucia: No, it won't.
Shure: 死不了放心真的
Shure: You won't die, trust me.
Jake:这个大家都是这么火的
Jake: Everyone does it like this.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 都已经如此生活30年了
Shure: We've been living like this for 30 years now.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 没事这个不会的啦这个没问题的
Lucia: No worries, this won't be a problem at all.
Shure: 没问题
Shure: No problem.
Jake:外边都是这么搞
Jake: Everyone does it this way outside.
Jake:并且我们这个是民牌插足
Jake: Plus, this is a reputable brand.
Alice:公牛是吗
Alice: Bull, right?
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Alice:看到公牛我放心了
Alice: When I see Bull, I'm relieved.
Shure: 然后就是坐这的同学稍微注意一些
Shure: So, those sitting here, please be a bit more careful.
Tasha: 哈哈由我来进行一个开箱仪式吗
Tasha: Haha, should I do an unboxing ceremony?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yes, yes, yes.
Tasha: 好好
Tasha: Okay, okay.
Lucia: 开箱的工作交给你了
Lucia: The unboxing is your job now.
Shure: 这白菜洗没洗呢
Shure: Has this cabbage been washed?
Lucia: 我负责取快递你负责开箱
Lucia: I handle the packages, you do the unboxing.
Shure: 那要不洗洗一下子
Shure: How about we wash it real quick?
Alice:确实得洗
Alice: Yeah, it should be washed.
Alice:金针菇啥的也得洗一下
Alice: Also, the enoki mushrooms need washing.
Alice:这种也得过一下
Alice: This too should be rinsed.
Lucia: 谢谢你
Lucia: Thank you.
Shure: 慢得和你走到散
Shure: Slow enough to walk with you.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Tasha: 啊哈
Tasha: Haha.
Alice:没洗手
Alice: Didn't wash hands.
Lucia: 不干不净吃了没病哈哈
Lucia: A little dirt won't hurt, haha.
Shure: 但是不干不净
Shure: But the dirt...
Shure: 喝了有病
Shure: Drinking it will make you sick.
Shure: 他们这样
Shure: They are like this.
Tasha: 他这个
Tasha: This one...
Jake:我怎么知道我订单尾号是什么
Jake: How am I supposed to know the last digits of my order?
Tasha: 感觉像诈骗
Tasha: Feels like a scam.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:不是不是订单尾号快递
Jake: No, no, it's the order number for the delivery.
Tasha: 什么时候吃晚饭
Tasha: When are we having dinner?
Lucia: 快
Lucia: Soon.
Shure: 打算在群里喊一下
Shure: Planning to announce it in the group.
Shure: 回家吃饭了
Shure: Time to go home for dinner.
Tasha:在群里吗
Tasha: In the group chat?
Jake:没吧没有没有没有
Jake: No, no, no.
Alice:可以再来一个吗
Alice: Can we have another one?
Tasha: 是啊
Tasha: Yeah.
Alice: 他们是不够了吗
Alice: Are they not enough?
Tasha: 没事不是每个人都要吃到一个
Tasha: It's okay, not everyone needs to have one.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice: 好再来一个吧
Alice: Alright, let's have another one.
Tasha: 啊这个能至于
Tasha: Uh, is this necessary?
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Alice:我也觉得
Alice: I think so too.
Alice:因为他没有被压
Alice: Because it wasn't pressed down.
Shure: 啊稍微稍微冲一下
Shure: Ah, just rinse it a bit.
Shure: 虽然这应该是干净的
Shure: Although it should be clean.
Tasha: 其实我想问这个
Tasha: Actually, I wanted to ask this.
Alice:嗯你说什么
Alice: Hmm, what did you say?
Tasha: 那个瓦斯罐应该装在哪
Tasha: Where should the gas canister be placed?
Shure: 装进去了
Shure: It's already placed in.
Tasha: 装进去吧
Tasha: Put it in.
Tasha: 嗯行
Tasha: Hmm, okay.
Shure: 我宿舍就有
Shure: I have one in my dorm.
Shure: 一个非非常不安全
Shure: But it's very, very unsafe.
Tasha: 我没有
Tasha: I don't have one.
Shure: 大家不要学
Shure: Don't learn from this, guys.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thank you.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 也可以烧水的哦
Shure: You can also boil water with it.
Shure: 电水热水壶
Shure: Electric kettle.
Tasha: 月饼
Tasha: Mooncake.
Shure: 还在楼下
Shure: It's still downstairs.
Tasha: 他们还有3个人是吧
Tasha: They still have 3 people, right?
Lucia: 对好想是
Lucia: Yeah, I think so.
Alice:我们学校前一段还着火了
Alice: Our school had a fire recently.
Tasha: 那好吧
Tasha: Oh, okay.
Jake:为什么呢
Jake: Why?
Jake:用擦板吃火锅
Jake: They were using a hot plate for hotpot.
Alice:嗯有人吸烟
Alice: Yeah, someone was smoking.
Alice:哦这好像不让说的
Alice: Oh, I think that's not allowed to be said.
Alice:无所谓哈哈
Alice: Whatever, haha.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice:没关系啊
Alice: It's alright.
Lucia: 关系没事他会把这段删掉的哈
Lucia: It's okay, he'll delete this part.
Jake:跪下不让说
Jake: Kneel and don't say anything.
Alice:不删也行无所谓
Alice: It's fine if he doesn't delete it.
Jake:是
Jake: Yes.
Shure: 有人逼逼哈哈哈
Shure: Someone is babbling, haha.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Tasha: 第一
Tasha: First.
Lucia: 那我给你手动做音效
Lucia: Then I'll make the sound effects for you.
Shure: 然后他在逼逼的时候他逼逼的哈哈
Shure: And when he babbles, he babbles, haha.
Lucia: 你现在说吧
Lucia: Go ahead and talk now.
Lucia: 哈哈哈咪哈哈
Lucia: Haha, mimihaha.
Alice:哈哈咦
Alice: Haha, yikes.
Jake:咦
Jake: Yikes.
Alice:无所谓这个
Alice: Doesn't matter.
Lucia: 我们学校之前也有过但好像是电动车
Lucia: Our school had something similar before, but it was an electric scooter.
Alice:然后那个救护车开到楼下了
Alice: Then the ambulance arrived downstairs.
Alice:我还在睡觉
Alice: I was still sleeping.
Alice:完全没有听到
Alice: Didn't hear anything at all.
Alice:他们在群里一直在吵我们要不要跑
Alice: They were arguing in the group chat, should we run?
Alice:要不要跑
Alice: Should we run?
Alice:没有听到声音
Alice: I didn't hear a thing.
Lucia: 大家精神状态都很稳定吗
Lucia: Is everyone mentally stable?
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice:小的不用跑
Alice: The small ones don't need to run.
Alice:大的跑不了
Alice: The big ones can't run.
Alice:洗菜
Alice: Wash the vegetables.
Jake:鼓手是
Jake: The drummer is...
Jake:就是是吧
Jake: ...right?
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Jake:哈哈啊
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 可以可以
Shure: Alright, alright.
Jake:打击乐手
Jake: The percussionist.
Alice:这点有餐盘啥的吗
Alice: Do we have any plates or something?
Lucia: 有
Lucia: Yes.
Alice:还是楼下有
Alice: Or are they downstairs?
Tasha: 这好像也有
Tasha: They should be here too.
Alice:洗一下吧
Alice: Let's wash them.
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: There's none.
Alice:这个不用洗
Alice: This doesn't need to be washed.
Lucia: sorry不是这个
Lucia: Sorry, not this one.
Tasha: 别的都不用好像
Tasha: I think nothing else needs to be washed.
Alice:这个不用
Alice: This one doesn't.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Okay.
Alice:这个需要吗
Alice: Do we need this?
Alice:嗯拿碟装吧
Alice: Hmm, let's put it on a plate.
Lucia: 嗯点的话不够
Lucia: Hmm, it won't be enough if we order.
Lucia: 咱有8个人
Lucia: We have 8 people.
Alice: 不不是这个
Alice: No, not this one.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Alice:你是不是得下楼亲
Alice: Do you need to go downstairs?
Alice:有没有大一点
Alice: Do we have a bigger one?
Lucia: 妙妙小工具
Lucia: A handy little tool.
Alice:我想要那个
Alice: I want that one.
Lucia: 那个
Lucia: That one?
Alice:我洗白菜啊
Alice: I'm washing the cabbage.
Lucia: 啊你说你说碗吗
Lucia: Oh, you mean the bowl?
Alice:大碗对
Alice: The big bowl, yes.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This one?
Alice:我洗白菜
Alice: I'm washing the cabbage.
Lucia: 这个碗我前两天洗过
Lucia: I washed this bowl a few days ago.
Lucia: 我涮一下就可以
Lucia: I'll just rinse it, it's fine.
Lucia: 对但其他的
Lucia: Yeah, but the others...
Lucia: 这上面的碗应该还没怎么用过
Lucia: The bowls up there shouldn't have been used much.
Lucia: 我先都拿出来
Lucia: I'll take them all out first.
Lucia: 就是先拿8个这个小碗
Lucia: Just get 8 of these small bowls first.
Alice:白菜手撕的好吃
Alice: Hand-torn cabbage tastes better.
Alice:谁懂
Alice: Who knows that?
Lucia: 啊太好了有白菜
Lucia: Oh, great, we have cabbage.
Lucia: 嗯我还以为白菜咱昨天用完了呢
Lucia: Hmm, I thought we used up all the cabbage yesterday.
Alice:没有我只用了叶没用包
Alice: No, I only used the leaves, not the core.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Okay.
Alice:这是定水的东西
Alice: This is for the water.
Lucia: 我到楼下看看楼下的碗够不够
Lucia: I'll go downstairs and check if there are enough bowls.
Lucia: 要楼下碗够
Lucia: If there are enough downstairs...
Lucia: 把楼下碗拿上来算了
Lucia: I'll just bring them up.
Lucia: 要不然话还得再涮一次太麻烦了
Lucia: Otherwise, we have to rinse them again, which is too much trouble.
Nicous: 我没有
Nicous: I don't have any.
Nicous: 我擦你你你你是大股
Nicous: Oh my, you, you, you are a major shareholder.
Lucia: 果果啊谢谢
Lucia: Guoguo, thank you.
Katrina: 这位
Katrina: This person.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Shure: 我们来来个同学帮我一下
Shure: Hey, can a classmate help me out here?
Jake:来要干啥
Jake: What do you need?
Shure: 直接倒到那里面
Shure: Just pour it in there directly.
Shure: 省得我一点一点接了是吧
Shure: So I don't have to scoop it bit by bit, right?
Katrina: 诶从哪搞两股啊
Katrina: Hey, where did you get these two?
Jake:哦哦走赶走
Jake: Oh, oh, go, go.
Shure: 然后这个拿着吧
Shure: And then hold this.
Katrina: 就有啊哦
Katrina: Got it, oh.
Shure: 别别让这个粘着那什么
Shure: Don't let it stick to anything.
Katrina: 我以为要借
Katrina: I thought you needed to borrow it.
Choiszt: 你们喝这个吗
Choiszt: Do you guys drink this?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Choiszt: ok
Choiszt: Okay.
Alice:然我说这洗不掉
Alice: I told you this wouldn't wash out.
Lucia: 好像有点
Lucia: Seems like it a bit.
Alice:这什么玩意
Alice: What is this thing?
Jake:就这样就行了
Jake: Just leave it like this, it's fine.
Lucia: 有就是有的菜叶子上它就
Lucia: Yeah, some veggies just...
Lucia: 就长这样还是怎么回事
Lucia: They just grow like this, or what's going on?
Lucia: 我们家洗菜也是
Lucia: Even when I wash veggies at home...
Lucia: 就是有时候这个东西它是洗不掉的
Lucia: Sometimes you just can't wash this off.
Alice:摸摸
Alice: Touch it.
Jake:倒个数据呗
Jake: Pour the data in, will you?
Lucia: 应该它就长这样
Lucia: It just grows like this.
Alice:好像长上去了一样
Alice: It's like it's grown onto it.
Lucia: 对它就长这样
Lucia: Yeah, it just grows like this.
Alice:好你给我做个见
Alice: Okay, can you vouch for me?
Alice:证啊
Alice: Please?
Alice:放心吧我确实洗了
Alice: Don't worry, I really did wash it.
Lucia: 好放心吧
Lucia: Okay, no worries.
Lucia: 他就长这样
Lucia: It grows like this.
Jake:哈
Jake: Haha.
Katrina: 哇哦
Katrina: Wow.
Shure: 这放放顶上
Shure: Put it on top.
Shure: 不然话我一会钻不过去
Shure: Otherwise, I can't fit through later.
Lucia: 他就这样
Lucia: It just grows like this.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure: 我对我自己几斤几两非常有点逼数
Shure: I'm very aware of my own abilities.
Shure: 你知道吧
Shure: You know that, right?
Lucia: 我踩着啥了刚才
Lucia: What did I just step on?
Shure: 呦呦呦
Shure: Oh, oh, oh
Lucia: 你小心小心
Lucia: Be careful, be careful.
Lucia: 主要是别碰到接口什么的地方
Lucia: Just don't touch any connectors or anything.
Shure: 私密马赛
Shure: Excuse me.
Katrina:  没事擦一下吧
Katrina: It's okay, just wipe it off.
Lucia: 呃楼上是不是没有抹布好像哎有
Lucia: Uh, is there no cloth upstairs? Oh, there is.
Tasha: 这个水明显少了
Tasha: This water is clearly less.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 没事我们一会拿那个开水直接补吧
Shure: It's okay, we'll just add some boiling water later.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:用娃哈哈的水
Jake: Use Wahaha water.
Katrina: 先拿抹布擦
Katrina: First, wipe it with a cloth.
Lucia: 呃
Lucia: Uh
Jake:啊用娃哈哈的水
Jake: Ah, use Wahaha water.
Lucia: 啊娃哈哈的水就是说它的水很健康啊
Lucia: Ah, Wahaha water, it means the water is very healthy.
Tasha: 就是说他的水很健康的感觉
Tasha: It means it feels like the water is very healthy.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Lucia: OK实验室用水
Lucia: OK, lab water.
Shure: 实验室 的
Shure: For the lab.
Jake:哈哈哈没有没有
Jake: Hahaha no, no.
Shure: 都在用
Shure: Everyone uses it.
Jake:我乱说的
Jake: I'm just kidding.
Jake:本身我们还有一个环节
Jake: Actually, we have another segment.
Jake:就是给你们五六种这种矿泉水
Jake: We give you five or six kinds of mineral water.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Mm.
Jake:让你们去分
Jake: And let you distinguish them.
Shure: 啊可以啊
Shure: Ah, that sounds good.
Katrina: 这是你设计的某种游戏吗
Katrina: Is this some game you designed?
Lucia: 然后呢谁先把这些水喝完谁是赢家吗
Lucia: And then, whoever finishes the water first is the winner?
Jake:谁能分辨得出来
Jake: Whoever can tell the difference.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Shure: 没海鲜
Shure: No seafood.
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow.
Shure: 少浅浅
Shure: Just a little bit.
Lucia: 额
Lucia: Uh
Shure: 没问题
Shure: No problem.
Shure: 万事俱备
Shure: Everything's ready
Shure: 只他娘的欠东风
Shure: Just missing the east wind
Shure: 东风是什么呢
Shure: What's the east wind?
Shure: 东风就是火锅底料
Shure: The east wind is the hot pot base
Jake:为什么
Jake: Why?
Tasha: 火锅底料呢
Tasha: The hot pot base?
Tasha: 那个那个所有的料的那个袋子
Tasha: The bag with all the ingredients
Lucia: 调料的袋子是吗
Lucia: The seasoning bag, right?
Tasha: 哦对
Tasha: Oh, yeah.
Lucia: 在楼下
Lucia: It's downstairs.
Tasha: 是不是还要拿一些
Tasha: Should we get some more?
Tasha: 8个碗 8个碟
Tasha: Eight bowls, eight plates.
Lucia: 呃碗有但盘子不够咱就用小碗吧
Lucia: Uh, we have bowls but not enough plates, let's use small bowls instead.
Lucia: 因为他这的盘子都是那种大一点的
Lucia: Because the plates here are kind of big.
Lucia: 而且好像没有8个
Lucia: And I don't think we have eight.
Lucia: 至少楼上没有
Lucia: At least not upstairs.
Lucia: 不过小碗已经都拿出来了
Lucia: But I already brought out the small bowls.
Tasha: 就拿碗吧
Tasha: Just use bowls then.
Lucia: 对然后那有3个是楼下洗过
Lucia: Yeah, and three of them are washed from downstairs.
Lucia: 我直接拿上来了
Lucia: I just brought them up.
Tasha: 一二三四五五个
Tasha: One, two, three, four, five, five bowls.
Lucia: 然后对然后
Lucia: And then, yeah, then
Tasha: 再拿三个碗
Tasha: Get three more bowls.
Lucia: 呃池子里应该还有几个
Lucia: Uh, there should be a few more in the sink.
Lucia: 反正我刚把底下都拿出来了
Lucia: Anyway, I already brought out everything from downstairs.
Lucia: 我先去拿一下那个调料
Lucia: I'll go get the seasoning first.
Tasha: 行
Tasha: Okay.
Lucia: 哎你已经找到了
Lucia: Hey, you already found it?
Shure: 我找到了啊
Shure: I found it.
Lucia: ok我看看那个是我的水来这
Lucia: Okay, let me see, that's my water there.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Shure: 呃
Shure: Uh.
Tasha: 他这个是写3-5人吃
Tasha: This says it's for 3-5 people.
Shure: 我们我们吃辣的水平是什么样的
Shure: What's our spice tolerance level?
Shure: 家人们
Shure: Everyone?
Katrina: 我很能吃辣
Katrina: I can eat really spicy food.
Shure: OK四个全
Shure: OK, all four of us
Shure: 下一个里
Shure: Put it all in.
Katrina: 哈哈哈总有刁民想害朕
Katrina: Hahaha, always some pesky people trying to harm me.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Shure: 辣辣不死你
Shure: Spicy enough to kill you.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahaha
Shure: 明天不用拍摄
Shure: No need to shoot tomorrow.
Shure: 大家都在厕所
Shure: Everyone will be in the bathroom.
Tasha: 那那就各分一半吧
Tasha: Then let's split it in half.
Shure: 哎呦呦
Shure: Oh, come on.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Lucia: 啊小心
Lucia: Ah, be careful.
Tasha: 各分一半了
Tasha: It's split in half now.
Shure: 行行行这就各分一半吧
Shure: Alright, let's split it in half.
Katrina: 强制下班喽case
Katrina: Forced to get off work now.
Lucia: 看一下啊
Lucia: Let's have a look.
Tasha: 那这个火锅底料反正是4块
Tasha: Anyway, there are four pieces of hotpot base.
Tasha: 不如一个里面下两块
Tasha: How about we put two pieces in each pot?
Shure: 就我一个人下两块
Shure: I'll put two pieces in one pot.
Katrina: 可以
Katrina: That's fine.
Shure: 这哪到哪
Shure: What's the point of this?
Shure: 撒撒嘴吧就是
Shure: Just to spice things up a bit.
Katrina: 刚从成都回来
Katrina: Just got back from Chengdu.
Shure: 香锅我也切来
Shure: I'll chop the fragrant pot too.
Tasha: 一个是两
Tasha: One is two...
Tasha: 一个锅是下两块
Tasha: One pot gets two pieces.
Tasha: 一个锅是下半袋
Tasha: One pot gets half a bag.
Lucia: 啊下半袋的意思是
Lucia: Ah, half a bag means...
Lucia: 是这个里面少下一块吗
Lucia: Does it mean putting one less piece in here?
Shure: 不是不是菌汤的内个
Shure: No, no, it's for the mushroom soup base.
Tasha:他们菌汤的内个
Tasha: It's for their mushroom soup base.
Lucia: 啊OK OK那这个也是拆开放到这里面
Lucia: Ah, OK, OK, then let's split it and put it in here.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Alright.
Lucia: 那我就拆了
Lucia: Then I'll open it.
Katrina:  嗯我们拆
Katrina: Hmm, let's open it.
Tasha:哎呀sorry
Tasha: Oh, sorry.
Tasha: 不要让两种味道混合
Tasha: Don't let the two flavors mix.
Shure: i missing you my honey
Shure: I miss you my honey.
Shure: don t you
Shure: Don't you?
Lucia: 怎么只有这一锅水最多
Lucia: Why is there only this pot with the most water?
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha: 啊这怎么办
Tasha: Ah, what should we do?
Shure: 什么一袋
Shure: What one bag?
Katrina: 怎么了
Tasha: 只有一袋
Tasha: There's only one bag.
Shure: 什么一袋不行吧
Shure: Just one bag? That's not enough.
Tasha: 我的建议是把这个袋子撕开
Tasha: My suggestion is to tear the bag open.
Tasha: 然后倒一半
Tasha: And then pour out half.
Shure: 这无需撕开
Shure: No need to tear it open.
Shure: 说明他不应该撕开
Shure: It means you shouldn't tear it open.
Tasha: 那怎么办
Tasha: Then what should we do?
Shure: 随便
Shure: Whatever.
Shure: 小公鸡点到谁我就选谁好啊
Shure: I'll just pick whoever the little rooster points to, okay?
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Tasha: 那这个锅的菌汤该有多么的孤单呀
Tasha: Then this pot's mushroom soup will be so lonely.
Tasha: 啊煮一半把它捞出来放这个锅里
Tasha: Ah, we'll cook half and then scoop it out and put it in this pot.
Shure: 哈哈哈流动料包
Shure: Hahaha, a flowing ingredient packet.
Lucia: 失策早知道两个锅当时应该买两包
Lucia: Bad planning. We should have bought two packets for two pots.
Shure: 哦你在切东西
Shure: Oh, are you cutting something?
Lucia: 嗯啊sorry
Lucia: Yeah, sorry.
Shure: 厕所有人吗
Shure: Is the bathroom occupied?
Shure: anyone
Shure: Anyone?
Lucia: 应该是没有的意思吧
Shure: come in
Shure: Come in.
Katrina:  没有人
Katrina: No one's here.
Shure: 我要进来喽
Shure: I'm coming in.
Tasha: 妈呀
Tasha: Oh my gosh.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Katrina:  最好近
Katrina: Better come in.
Lucia: 好多预热啊哈哈哈
Lucia: So much buildup, haha.
Shure: 嘿嘿嘿
Shure: Hehehe.
Katrina:  三次握手才出
Katrina: Three handshakes to get in.
Lucia: 3次握手才能确定
Lucia: Three handshakes to confirm.
Lucia: 正在进行握手
Lucia: In the middle of a handshake.
Lucia: 我觉得我们家网经常握手它就握不
Lucia: I think our home internet often handshakes, and it just doesn't connect.
Shure: 这只扔了
Shure: Throw this one away.
Lucia: 上了
Lucia: Got it.
Lucia: 十五秒抓把鸭肠
Lucia: Grab some duck intestines in fifteen seconds.
Shure: 我们那个河马的那些袋子拿一个
Shure: Let's take one of those bags from Hema.
Shure: 然后当一个垃圾袋吧
Shure: And use it as a trash bag.
Lucia: 盒马袋子还有吗
Lucia: Do we still have Hema bags?
Lucia: 我去看看
Lucia: I'll go check.
Shure: 有吧应该
Shure: Should be, right?
Lucia: 哎我把我手机又撂哪
Lucia: Hey, where did I leave my phone?
Lucia: 哎算放那了
Lucia: Eh, whatever, leave it there.
Lucia: 我感觉用完了
Lucia: I feel like it's used up.
Lucia: 呦就你了
Lucia: Hey, it's you.
Lucia: behold
Lucia: Behold.
Shure: 好啊好啊
Shure: Okay, okay.
Shure: 他拿了一个大袋子
Shure: He took a big bag.
Shure: 哪边水不够我们再补一点
Shure: We'll add more water if there's not enough on that side.
Lucia: 我觉得这这是不是俩都有点少看起来
Lucia: I feel like both of these look a bit less.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 是不是应该拿个小盘
Shure: Should we get a small plate?
Shure: 这样然后这个是辣锅烧是吧
Shure: Like this, and this is the spicy hot pot, right?
Lucia: 对辣锅与旁边的菌汤少可以了
Lucia: Yes, the spicy hot pot and the mushroom soup on the side should be enough.
Shure: 天啊太气
Shure: Oh my god, so annoying.
Shure: 把那个门关上吧你们
Shure: Close that door, you guys.
Lucia: 哦微
Lucia: Oh, Tasha.
Shure: 不然话会窜进去味的
Shure: Otherwise, the smell will spread.
Tasha: 嗯嗯
Tasha: Hmm, okay.
Lucia: 微你的门或者我帮你关
Lucia: Tasha, your door, or I can help you close it.
Lucia: 如果你不介意的话
Lucia: If you don't mind.
Tasha: 没关系
Tasha: It's okay.
Shure: 关好哦大家
Shure: Close it tight, everyone.
Lucia: 我看看我那边啊
Lucia: Let me check on my side.
Lucia: 我把我那边也关上
Lucia: I'll close mine too.
Alice:你们介意我把这个魔芋直接拽成
Alice: Do you guys mind if I just pull this konjac apart?
Shure: 不介意拽吧
Shure: No, go ahead and pull it apart.
Shure: 我不介意
Shure: I don't mind.
Shure: 有介意的吗
Shure: Anyone mind?
Lucia: 不介意
Lucia: I don't mind.
Shure: 他们不敢介意了好拽吧
Shure: They don't dare to mind, go ahead.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Alice: 好
Alice: Alright.
Shure: 对我们觉得拽着香
Shure: Yeah, we think it smells good when pulled apart.
Shure: 就像手撕白菜一样
Shure: Just like tearing cabbage by hand.
Lucia: 哦原来魔芋块是长这样的
Lucia: Oh, so that's what konjac blocks look like.
Alice: 行放飞自我了
Alice: Alright, let loose!
Lucia: 小心手要不要把那个盘
Lucia: Be careful with your hands. Do you want that plate?
Lucia: 案板是在楼下是吗
Lucia: The chopping board is downstairs, right?
Lucia: 我再去拿一下好了
Lucia: I'll go get it.
Alice:没事我已经切完了
Lucia: 啊那行
Alice:哈哈好像阴暗扭曲的一个人
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: 嗯
Alice:还有什么要弄的
Tasha: 好像没有了
Alice:坐你旁边吧有纸吗
Alice: 谢谢
Alice:再来一个吧谢谢
Lucia: 放到这儿沾
Alice:我感觉我快没有吃蠢鼠
Tasha: 嗯蘸料呢哦
Tasha: 蘸料是拿来了吗
Alice:山药是不是还搁底下呢
Alice: Is the yam still at the bottom?
Lucia: 蘸料刚才好像修硕已经开了
Lucia: I think Shure just opened the dipping sauce earlier.
Alice:是不是在底下呀
Alice: Is it at the bottom?
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
Tasha: 醋碟油碟
Tasha: Vinegar dish, oil dish.
Shure: 呃都我只把麻酱给卸了
Shure: Uh, I only unpacked the sesame paste.
Alice:没有油条就麻酱
Alice: No youtiao, just sesame sauce.
Lucia: 蘸料你是不是打开了一个
Lucia: Did you open a dipping sauce?
Tasha: 买了油买了
Tasha: Bought the oil, got it.
Alice:我没有醋吗
Alice: Do we not have vinegar?
Shure: 其他的还还没弄
Shure: Haven't done the rest yet.
Lucia: 呃有点买了一个小的
Lucia: Uh, bought a small one.
Lucia: 我去把它拿上来
Lucia: I'll go get it.
Tasha: 嗯有点粗点
Tasha: Hmm, it's a bit thick.
Lucia: 布谷
Lucia: Cuckoo.
Lucia: 噔噔噔
Lucia: Dun dun dun.
Jake:20分钟 20分钟下来
Jake: 20 minutes, 20 minutes left.
Jake:那没问题
Jake: No problem.
Jake:还有一个小时呗
Jake: There's still an hour left.
Lucia: 算了我也不知道在哪儿
Lucia: Never mind, I don't know where it is.
Shure: 大家想看什么呀
Shure: What do you guys want to watch?
Lucia: 那个麻将我不太清楚放哪了
Lucia: I'm not sure where the sesame sauce is.
Lucia: 但是这两个可以拿上来
Lucia: But we can bring these two up.
Shure: 放在楼下的这个这个地方
Shure: It's downstairs in that spot.
Lucia: 啊确定吗
Lucia: Ah, are you sure?
Lucia: 我感觉那一块只有一些烘焙原料
Lucia: I feel like that area only has some baking ingredients.
Shure: 不他那一大碗就是麻酱
Shure: No, that big bowl is just sesame paste.
Lucia: 啊哈我再看一眼
Lucia: Ah, okay, let me take another look.
Shure: 对那个碗是我卸好的麻酱
Shure: Yeah, that bowl is the sesame paste I prepared.
Jake:你在用卡了40G
Jake: You've already used 40GB.
Tasha: 嗯吃完火锅
Tasha: Yeah, after finishing hot pot.
Tasha: 晚吗
Tasha: Is it late?
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This...
Lucia: 先放在这大家一会自己
Lucia: Let's put it here for now, everyone can...
Tasha: 啊人怎么又不见了的感觉
Tasha: Ah, it feels like someone's missing again.
Lucia: 呃有俩人在楼下
Lucia: Uh, there are two people downstairs.
Alice:他们回来了吗
Alice: Have they come back?
Lucia: 哎不对啊
Lucia: Wait, no...
Lucia: 应该有三个回
Lucia: There should be three coming back.
Lucia: 回来了应该回来了
Lucia: They should be back, they should be back.
Lucia: 应该有三个人在楼下呀
Lucia: There should be three people downstairs.
Alice: 这个火用不用加粗
Alice: Do we need to turn up the heat?
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Alice: 这个稍微多一点
Alice: This one, a bit more.
Tasha: 这边这个为什么都冒气
Tasha: Why is this side steaming?
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Lucia: 他是不是要把火再开大一些
Lucia: Should we turn up the heat a bit more?
Tasha:这是不是已经最大了
Tasha: Is this the maximum already?
Alice: 加不了
Alice: Can't go higher.
Alice:这个水比这个水多一点慢一点
Alice: This water is a bit more than this one, so it's slower.
Tasha: 啊可能这边受热不均匀
Tasha: Ah, maybe this side isn't heating evenly.
Tasha: 你看它这个圆圈在这里
Tasha: Look, the circle is here.
Tasha: 它这个圆圈
Tasha: This circle...
Shure: 知道为什么吗因为
Shure: Do you know why? Because...
Tasha: 这样
Tasha: Like this.
Shure: 它的功率大一点
Shure: The power is a bit higher.
Shure: 哈哈哈没有什么为什么
Shure: Hahaha, no real reason.
Shure: 哦好
Shure: Oh, okay.
Alice:这个水还少呢
Alice: There's still less water here.
Shure: 是因为那个
Shure: It's because...
Shure: 我后来不是把开水几乎都加在这边了
Shure: I added almost all the boiling water here later.
Tasha: 哦这边加的是开水
Tasha: Oh, you added boiling water here.
Shure: 所以他开水加的多一点
Shure: So there's more boiling water here.
Alice:晚上就熏入味了
Alice: It'll get infused with flavor by tonight.
Lucia: 哎你已经把他打开了
Lucia: Hey, you've already opened it.
Shure: 有酒能不喝开玩笑
Shure: How can you have alcohol and not drink it, are you kidding?
Lucia: 已经把朗姆酒打开了
Lucia: The rum is already opened.
Alice:看来这马上要没了
Alice: Looks like this is going to be gone soon.
Alice:没存储现在已经快3小时了
Alice: It's been almost 3 hours without saving.
Shure: 橙汁补满螺丝棋子
Shure: Refill the orange juice and screws.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Alice:只有20
Alice: Only 20.
Tasha: 这是什么
Tasha: What is this?
Tasha: 哦好吧
Tasha: Oh, okay.
Shure: 好喝的小甜水
Shure: It's a nice sweet drink.
Shure: 一些酒鬼
Shure: Some drunkards.
Shure: 我可以让火小一点了
Shure: I can make the fire smaller now.
Alice:上面有水吗
Alice: Is there water on top?
Shure: 有啊没有
Shure: Yes, there isn't.
Tasha: 喝可乐就行
Tasha: Just drink cola.
Tasha: 中午的可乐
Tasha: The noon cola.
Tasha: 我觉得火锅应该喝可乐
Tasha: I think hotpot should go with cola.
Shure: 可乐有
Shure: There's cola.
Shure: 还有啤酒要吗
Shure: And beer, do you want some?
Tasha: 小孩来这桌哈哈
Tasha: Kids, come to this table, haha.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 还有soda water
Shure: There's also soda water.
Shure: 气泡水
Shure: Sparkling water.
Tasha: 椰子水也有
Tasha: There's coconut water too.
Shure: 筷子拿来了吗
Shure: Did you bring the chopsticks?
Alice: 上面有吗
Alice: Are there any on top?
Shure: 上面也有
Shure: There are some on top too.
Alice:你要水不要
Alice: Do you need water?
Alice:我去拿一瓶
Alice: I'll go get a bottle.
Tasha: 要什么
Tasha: Need anything?
Alice:我去拿哦
Alice: I'll go get it.
Tasha: 你可以拿对
Tasha: You can get it, right?
Tasha: 然后对你不喝饮料吗
Tasha: And aren't you going to drink anything?
Alice:还有啥需要拿上来的
Alice: Anything else we need to bring up?
Tasha: 筷子有了
Tasha: We have chopsticks.
Shure: 想起来啥拿啥
Shure: Just bring whatever you think of.
Tasha: 是不是少啊
Tasha: Is it enough?
Shure: 楼下还有筷子
Shure: There are more chopsticks downstairs.
Tasha: 哦还有碗是不是够
Tasha: Oh, and bowls, are there enough?
Shure: 对碗
Shure: Yes, bowls.
Alice:碗够吗
Alice: Are there enough bowls?
Lucia: 碗够了应该
Lucia: The bowls should be enough.
Shure: 也
Shure: Yeah.
Tasha: 碗和筷子就行了吧
Tasha: Bowls and chopsticks should be fine, right?
Lucia: 八个碗吗应该够了
Lucia: Eight bowls should be enough.
Alice:拿筷子呢
Alice: What about chopsticks?
Shure: 筷子筷子都拿上来吧
Shure: Bring all the chopsticks up.
Lucia: 筷子
Lucia: Chopsticks.
Alice:都拿上来
Alice: Bring them all up.
Lucia: 现在有一二为
Lucia: So now we have one, two...
Shure: 反正是8个人
Shure: Anyway, there are 8 people.
Lucia: 什么是5根筷子
Lucia: What's with the five pairs of chopsticks?
Tasha: 他拿走了一根
Tasha: He took one.
Tasha: 那就是四双
Tasha: So it's four pairs.
Lucia: 哦你拿走了一根
Lucia: Oh, you took one.
Lucia: 我以为你拿走了一双呢
Lucia: I thought you took a pair.
Tasha: 四双筷子
Tasha: Four pairs of chopsticks.
Tasha: 还差四双
Tasha: We still need four more pairs.
Alice:那我先去拿
Alice: I'll go get them.
Lucia: 我刚想说你倒的好像很多
Lucia: I was just about to say you poured a lot.
Lucia: 但我以为是你比较能喝
Lucia: But I thought you could handle it.
Shure: 差不多吧
Shure: Almost, I guess.
Lucia: 那个气泡酒能开吗
Lucia: Can we open the sparkling wine?
Shure: 气泡酒开了就得喝了今天
Shure: Once you open the sparkling wine, you have to finish it today.
Lucia: 确实哦因为气泡酒加橙汁很好喝
Lucia: True, sparkling wine with orange juice is really good.
Lucia: 让我想一想怎么办啧啧啧
Lucia: Let me think about what to do, hmm.
Shure: 怎么路边的野花不是不要采吗
Shure: Isn't it that you're not supposed to pick wildflowers by the roadside?
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Huh?
Shure: 没有没有
Shure: Never mind, never mind.
Shure: 跟跟别人说话
Shure: Talking to someone else.
Lucia: 突然串台了
Lucia: Suddenly got mixed up.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Shure: 开饭了可以吃了
Shure: Dinner's ready, we can eat now.
Alice:叫了嗯但是无动于衷
Alice: I called them, but no response.
Shure: 笑了吗OK
Shure: Did they laugh? OK.
Tasha: 无动于衷
Tasha: No response.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure: 再无动于衷咱就开吃
Shure: If they don't respond, we'll start eating.
Shure: 不等他们
Shure: Not waiting for them.
Shure: 惯着他们
Shure: Spoiling them.
Shure: 一天天的
Shure: Every single day...
Alice:先没有筷子
Alice: First, we have no chopsticks.
Shure: 吃饭都不积极
Shure: You're not even enthusiastic about eating.
Alice:你要尖筷子还是圆筷子
Alice: Do you want sharp chopsticks or round chopsticks?
Tasha: 啊呃
Tasha: Ah, uh...
Alice:只有一双圆筷子
Alice: There's only one pair of round chopsticks.
Tasha: 那就是好
Tasha: That's fine.
Tasha: 那我就要这双特殊的圆筷子
Tasha: Then I'll take this special pair of round chopsticks.
Tasha: 不我还是要尖筷子吧
Tasha: No, I'll take the sharp chopsticks instead.
Alice:那我也要
Alice: I'll take them too.
Alice:我要跟你一样
Alice: I want to be like you.
Alice:算了我用圆的吧
Alice: Never mind, I'll use the round ones.
Katrina:  换拖鞋
Katrina: Change slippers.
Alice:因为尖的我可能夹不住
Alice: Because with the sharp ones, I might not be able to pick things up.
Lucia: 我也来一点
Lucia: I'll have a bit too.
Shure: 高点
Shure: Higher.
Lucia: 哈哈对
Lucia: Haha, right.
Lucia: 不过我不敢倒你那么多
Lucia: But I don't dare to pour as much as you.
Shure: 哎好了好了可以了
Shure: Alright, alright, that's enough.
Shure: 你为什么不用杯子呀
Shure: Why don't you use a cup?
Lucia: 啊因为我懒
Lucia: Ah, because I'm lazy.
Tasha: 现在不给直播了
Tasha: No more live streaming now.
Lucia: 就是我把这个喝完了
Lucia: I'll just finish this drink first.
Lucia: 我就可以直接拿它来吃饭了哈哈
Lucia: Then I can use it to eat directly, haha.
Tasha: 我不知道结果
Tasha: I don't know the result.
Shure: 来点嘛雨轩
Shure: Come on, Yuxuan, have some.
Katrina:  啊
Katrina: Ah.
Katrina:  喝
Katrina: Drink.
Shure: 喝
Shure: Drink.
Katrina:  喝
Katrina: Drink.
Katrina:  这是橙汁还是啥东西
Katrina: Is this orange juice or what?
Shure: 就是橙汁加朗姆酒
Shure: It's just orange juice with rum.
Shure: 好像橙汁不够
Shure: Seems like there's not enough orange juice.
Katrina:  试一下我不知道朗姆酒是什么味
Katrina: I'll try, I don't know what rum tastes like.
Shure: 你其实对你们都喝不出来什么味
Shure: Honestly, you guys can't really taste it.
Katrina:  扫一下
Katrina: Scan it.
Lucia: 啊太小看人了吧哈
Lucia: Ah, you're underestimating people, haha.
Shure: 选个片吧选个片吧
Shure: Let's pick a movie, let's pick a movie.
Shure: 别让我的大脸在这地方待着
Shure: Don't let my big face stay in this place.
Shure: 太太可怕了
Shure: It's terrifying.
Tasha: 是一个独立的国家
Tasha: It's an independent country.
Alice:为什么还是这个龙啊
Alice: Why is it still this dragon?
Tasha: 还是这局
Tasha: It's still this game.
Katrina:  哎着么把壁纸换了
Katrina: Hey, how do I change the wallpaper?
Shure: 这是我iPad壁纸
Shure: This is my iPad wallpaper.
Jake:啊这个能剥吗
Jake: Ah, can this be peeled?
Alice:啊啊吓我一跳
Alice: Ah, you scared me!
Tasha: 什么这个能播吗
Tasha: What, can this be aired?
Jake:这个能剥吗
Jake: Can this be peeled?
Tasha: 这为什么不能播
Tasha: Why can't this be aired?
Shure: 你还帮忙监督着是吗哈哈
Shure: Are you also helping to supervise? Haha.
Katrina:  那是我注意美硕
Katrina: I'm paying attention to Shure.
Tasha: 哦刚刚那段话吗
Tasha: Oh, that comment just now?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: I don't know.
Shure: 我也很开心
Shure: I'm also very happy.
Shure: 因为我有酒喝
Shure: Because I have alcohol to drink.
Lucia: 没事就算橙汁用完了
Lucia: It's okay, even if the orange juice runs out.
Lucia: 咱还有可乐
Lucia: We still have cola.
Shure: 这个兑可乐好喝吗
Shure: Is it good to mix it with cola?
Lucia: 自由古巴
Lucia: Cuba Libre.
Tasha: 怎么了
Tasha: What's up?
Lucia: 自由古巴的传统兑法吗
Lucia: It's the traditional way to mix Cuba Libre, right?
Tasha: 这是一道裂痕
Tasha: It's a crack.
Lucia: 这不是老母加可乐
Lucia: It's not just rum and cola.
Alice:你这屏幕裂了吗还是膜
Alice: Is your screen cracked or is it the screen protector?
Tasha: 不是膜
Tasha: It's not the protector.
Tasha: 什么时候开饭
Tasha: When are we starting dinner?
Jake:可以开了是吧
Jake: We can start, right?
Shure: 可以开始了
Shure: We can start.
Shure: 其实摆起来吧咱们
Shure: Actually, let's set it up.
Alice:碗没拿过来
Alice: Didn't bring the bowls over.
Jake:那就摆起来
Jake: Then let's set it up.
Jake:摆起来开
Jake: Set it up and start.
Shure: 然后把这个机器停了吧
Shure: And let's stop this machine.
Shure: 别别弄坏了
Shure: Don't break it.
Jake:开
Jake: Start.
Jake:这个开完就结束录制
Jake: Once we start, we'll finish the recording.
Shure: 可以
Shure: Okay.
Jake:开把摆起来
Jake: Start setting it up.
Tasha: 哦然后又不不不录了就开始正正哦
Tasha: Oh, and then no no no, start recording right.
Jake:然后就不录对对对
Jake: And then stop recording, right right.
Alice:啊蚂蚁爬上来了
Alice: Ah, ants are climbing up.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah!
Alice: 14
Alice: 14.
Jake:这怎么开
Jake: How do you open this?
Jake:这叫刀划吗
Jake: Is this how you cut with a knife?
Choiszt: 坐那儿
Choiszt: Sit there.
Tasha:好外卖
Tasha: Okay, takeout.
Choiszt: 这是在
Choiszt: This is...
Jake:哎在哪就
Jake: Hey, where is it...
Nicous: 割了
Nicous: Cut it.
Alice: 在那儿
Alice: Over there.
Jake:有有刀是 吗
Jake: Do we have a knife?
Shure: 我还没没确定坐那
Shure: I haven't decided where to sit yet.
Shure: 橙汁不够了
Shure: We're out of orange juice.
Shure: 可能有点浓
Shure: Might be a bit strong.
Katrina:  开了没那我加一点
Katrina: Is it ready? Then I'll add some.
Shure: 啊可以往里兑氧和毒
Shure: Oh, you can mix in some oxygen and poison.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 这个也开了吧要不
Lucia: Should we open this one too?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Nicous: 我擦两个锅搞这么豪华
Nicous: Whoa, two pots, going all out.
Jake:8个人两个过合适吧
Jake: Two pots for eight people should be fine, right?
Choiszt: 合适很开的
Choiszt: It's fine, very open.
Lucia: 特别合适
Lucia: Perfect.
Nicous: 我这8个锅
Nicous: I have eight pots.
Lucia: 这这好紧啊
Lucia: This is so tight.
Jake:看你直播
Jake: Watch your live stream.
Choiszt: 那内个刀开
Choiszt: That knife is open.
Lucia: 啊好
Lucia: Ah, okay.
Lucia: 谢谢我看看有啥人能直接撕的
Lucia: Thanks, let me see if there's anything I can rip open.
Shure: 我们看点什么
Shure: What should we watch?
Lucia: 这是不能撕开啊
Lucia: This can't be torn open, can it?
Shure: 我们看点啥
Shure: What should we watch?
Lucia: 这能撕开耶
Lucia: This can be torn open!
Tasha: 是你们3个人的绿豆糕
Tasha: Here’s your mung bean cakes for the three of you.
Katrina:  啊
Katrina: Ah.
Tasha: 因为你们3个刚刚不在
Tasha: Because the three of you weren't here just now.
Choiszt: 嗷谢谢这你做的吗
Choiszt: Oh, thanks. Did you make this?
Nicous: 这么好
Nicous: This is so nice.
Tasha: 呃你猜
Tasha: Uh, you guess.
Jake:是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes.
Lucia: 可以试
Lucia: Can I try?
Jake:这是一个好问题
Jake: That's a good question.
Jake:一款可以问PUA
Jake: You can ask PUA about it.
Choiszt: 人家做的就好吃
Choiszt: When someone else makes it, it's delicious.
Choiszt: 期待你做的
Choiszt: Looking forward to what you'll make.
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Hey.
Lucia: 虾滑就下的时候再撕吧
Lucia: Tear the shrimp balls when you're putting them in.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 呃这这这咋放呀
Lucia: Uh, how do we put this?
Jake:这个怎么
Jake: How do you...
Jake:这是这是那个
Jake: This is, this is that...
Lucia: 这是那个豆皮啥的应该
Lucia: This is like tofu skin or something, I think.
Lucia: 啊谢谢那我把这弄开
Lucia: Ah, thanks. I'll open this.
Lucia: 咱为啥买了两个毛肚哎呦妈
Lucia: Why did we buy two types of tripe? Oh my gosh.
Shure: 经典搞笑是吧
Shure: Classic comedy, right?
Alice:这撕了吗
Alice: Has this been torn?
Shure: 吓得我特烦恼
Shure: This scared me so much, I'm so annoyed.
Lucia: 呀
Lucia: Ah!
Jake:我靠
Jake: Damn.
Lucia: 撕了撕了
Lucia: Tore it, tore it.
Lucia: 但是它里面还有个袋子
Lucia: But there's another bag inside.
Jake:随便看看
Jake: Just take a look.
Jake:这段不录你爱怎么
Jake: This part's not recorded, do what you want.
Lucia: 我知道外面这层撕了
Lucia: I know, I tore the outer layer.
Jake:哎不对
Jake: Hey, no.
Lucia: 里面那可能是我也不知道它啥意思
Lucia: The inside, I'm not sure what it means.
Jake:有一圈摄像头在录
Jake: There's a circle of cameras recording.
Lucia: 下的时候再撕还是什么吧
Lucia: Tear it when putting it in, or something.
Shure: 就是要放能播的是吗
Shure: Just put what's broadcastable, right?
Lucia: 没事没事
Lucia: It's okay, it's okay.
Jake:放脸能播的
Jake: Put what's broadcastable.
Jake:go Pro还在拍
Jake: The GoPro is still recording.
Choiszt: 真毛肚假毛肚
Choiszt: Is it real tripe or fake tripe?
Lucia: 真真的吧
Lucia: It's real, right?
Tasha: 素毛肚吧
Tasha: It's vegetarian tripe, I guess.
Jake:就是你你在塞博吃火锅
Jake: So you're eating hotpot in Cyber?
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Choiszt: 拍拍照片看 内个配料表
Choiszt: Take a photo, check the ingredient list.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This one.
Alice:洗一下吗这个
Alice: Should we wash this?
Lucia: 不知
Lucia: I don't know.
Choiszt: 洗一下吧洗一下吧
Choiszt: Let's wash it, let's wash it.
Nicous: 你洗吧我手洗不了
Nicous: You wash it, I can't wash it with my hands.
Choiszt: 带眼镜的来洗
Choiszt: The one with glasses, come wash it.
Shure: 不干不净
Shure: A little dirt doesn't matter.
Shure: 吃了没病
Shure: Eating it won't make you sick.
Lucia: 我哎
Lucia: Oh, I...
Lucia: 我以为他这种包装都是直接吃的嘞
Lucia: I thought this kind of packaging was ready to eat.
Lucia: 不了解
Lucia: I didn't know.
Choiszt: 8点32修硕洗毛肚
Choiszt: At 8:32, Shure washed the tripe.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Shure: 给大家表演一个人类洗毛肚啊
Shure: I'll show everyone how to wash tripe.
Jake:可以记下来
Jake: You can write it down.
Shure: 我现在是场记
Shure: I'm the script supervisor now.
Lucia: 啊你真的系了
Lucia: Oh, you really tied it.
Choiszt: 真的
Choiszt: Really.
Tasha: 把这个包
Tasha: Take this bag.
Lucia: 记一些高光时刻是
Lucia: Note some highlight moments.
Choiszt: 记了方便你们方便你们定定位吧
Choiszt: Note it down to make it easier for you to locate.
Alice:这个没有吗
Alice: Is there none of this?
Katrina:  没他只有一个包当时只买了一个包
Katrina: No, we only bought one bag at the time.
Tasha: 所以我们决定两边一起共用
Tasha: So we decided to share both sides.
Katrina:  yes
Katrina: Yes.
Shure: 经典不知道看什么时候
Shure: A classic, I don't know when to watch it.
Shure: 就看点夏洛特烦恼
Shure: Let's watch "Goodbye Mr. Loser".
Nicous: 18分看直播洗完了
Nicous: 18 minutes into the live stream, done washing.
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha
Choiszt: 我槽不用记这么细
Choiszt: I didn't need to note it in such detail.
Nicous: 我也一开始细
Nicous: I also started with details.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Jake:迭代一下
Jake: Iterate.
Jake:还没迭代
Jake: Still not iterating.
Jake:迭代迭代
Jake: Iterate, iterate.
Jake:多换几个
Jake: Change a few more.
Lucia: 耶
Lucia: Yay
Jake:人气就一直很嗨
Jake: The vibe has been super high all along
Shure: 哈
Shure: Haha
Lucia: 宝你的筷子我放这儿可以吗
Lucia: Babe, can I put your chopsticks here?
Katrina:  可以
Katrina: Sure
Choiszt: 没有碗
Choiszt: There's no bowl
Nicous: 空调开吗
Nicous: Should we turn on the air conditioner?
Jake:开空调吗
Jake: Turn on the air conditioner?
Lucia: 我直接我建议我直接用碗喝水了
Lucia: I suggest just using a bowl to drink water
Lucia: 所以一会就用这个碗吃
Lucia: So later I'll use this bowl to eat
Jake:遥控器在哪啊空调
Jake: Where's the remote for the air conditioner?
Lucia: 嗯好问题
Lucia: Hmm, good question
Alice:是不在那个沙发上那个是吗
Alice: Is it on that sofa over there?
Lucia: 黑色这是吗
Lucia: The black one, is it?
Katrina:  白色
Katrina: The white one
Shure: 黑色是电视
Shure: The black one is for the TV
Lucia: ok放
Lucia: Okay, put it down
Alice:是不是开空调的时候放下去了还是
Alice: Did someone put it down when turning on the air conditioner or something?
Lucia: 内个
Lucia: That
Shure: 这也不是
Shure: Not this one either
Shure: 这是那什么的
Shure: This is for something else
Jake:放下去了吗
Jake: Did someone put it down?
Lucia: 好的吧
Lucia: Maybe
Shure: 这呢我放这了
Shure: Here it is, I put it here
Jake:瞅一瞅去找一找啊
Jake: Take a look and find it
Alice:是吗
Alice: Really?
Jake:这个像确实像
Jake: This looks like it, really looks like it
Shure: 就这就是
Shure: Yep, this is it
Lucia: what's this
Lucia: What's this
Shure: 谁调到22度我妈妈在家不揍你
Shure: Who set it to 22 degrees? My mom would beat you at home
Tasha:我
Tasha: I did
Shure: 26度调好了
Shure: Set it to 26 degrees, done
Jake:保护地球
Jake: Save the planet
Jake:人人有责哈哈哈
Jake: Everyone's responsibility, hahaha
Shure: 就是这你说录进去多不好啊
Shure: If this gets recorded, it would be so embarrassing
Shure: 我们还用空调
Shure: We're still using the air conditioner
Katrina:  我道歉
Katrina: I apologize
Shure: 他真的一点听不到哎
Shure: He really can't hear anything at all
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈我们仿佛在看默剧一样
Shure: Hahaha, it's like we're watching a silent movie
Choiszt: 12生肖吧
Choiszt: The 12 zodiac signs, right?
Jake:嚯这确实经典
Jake: Whoa, that's a classic.
Katrina:  ok
Katrina: Ok.
Jake:来我们干个杯
Jake: Let's have a toast.
Jake:就come杯
Jake: Just a quick toast.
Lucia: 这是
Lucia: This is...
Katrina:  come杯
Katrina: A toast.
Jake:有有杯子吗
Jake: Do we have cups?
Katrina:  哇我可是
Katrina: Wow, I...
Alice:多了
Alice: We have plenty.
Jake:好好杯子
Jake: Good, good, cups.
Katrina:  多放多少
Katrina: How much should we pour?
Shure: 一个小时
Shure: An hour.
Shure: 应该喝不出来什么
Shure: You probably won't taste much.
Katrina:  有一点味道
Katrina: There's a bit of flavor.
Jake:我要把我爸把我茅台打上来
Jake: I'm bringing up my dad's Maotai.
Shure: 吧
Shure: Sure.
Choiszt: 我这儿那我干了
Choiszt: I'll finish mine here.
Shure: 那边一个这边一个
Shure: One there, one here.
Katrina:  这儿有人坐吗
Katrina: Is someone sitting here?
Choiszt: 开有首诗
Choiszt: There's a poem.
Katrina:  这不好坐看不到
Katrina: It's not a good seat, can't see.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Haha.
Katrina:  这儿老板
Katrina: Boss, sit here.
Shure: 你往你往这边
Shure: Move this way.
Shure: 我们挤一挤
Shure: Let's squeeze in.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Katrina:  老板坐这儿每个人都看那儿
Katrina: Boss, sit here, everyone can see.
Shure: 中间串一个
Shure: One in the middle.
Choiszt: 从他那儿搬一个
Choiszt: Move one from there.
Nicous: 还少一个啊不少了
Nicous: Still missing one? Not really.
Tasha: 他不用看电视
Tasha: He doesn't need to watch TV.
Tasha: 他要观察志愿者
Tasha: He's observing the volunteers.
Nicous: 这是什么电视电影
Nicous: What movie is this?
Shure: 夏洛特烦恼哈哈
Shure: "Goodbye Mr. Loser," haha.
Nicous: 我高中还演
Nicous: I acted in it in high school.
Tasha: 还演过
Tasha: You acted?
Nicous: 你我演的是什么角色
Nicous: What role did I play?
Shure: 你演的是圆滑
Shure: You played the smooth talker.
Nicous: 不是
Nicous: No.
Alice:这个车标
Alice: This car logo
Lucia: 玛莎拉蒂
Lucia: Maserati
Alice:他演了这个烧饼
Alice: He acted in this pancake skit
Nicous: 我演的是模特啥
Nicous: I acted as a model or something
Lucia: 哦哈哈
Lucia: Oh haha
Choiszt: 我现在下什么
Choiszt: What should I do now?
Jake:干杯吧
Jake: Cheers
Shure: 干杯
Shure: Cheers
Jake:干杯
Jake: Cheers
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Katrina:  你喝这啊
Katrina: Are you drinking this?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes
Katrina:  ok
Katrina: Okay
Lucia: 啊那还行
Lucia: Ah, that's fine then
Lucia: 那我拿这玩意也不是那么突兀
Lucia: Then holding this thing isn't that awkward
Jake:哈哈哈确实
Jake: Hahaha, indeed
Lucia: 哈哈哈谢谢你哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha, thank you haha
Jake:来干杯
Jake: Come on, cheers
Jake:干杯
Jake: Cheers
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Let's go
Jake:干杯
Jake: Cheers
Shure: eagle life票房大卖哈哈哈
Shure: Eagle Life box office hit hahaha
Jake:来药房大卖
Jake: Come on, pharmacy hits
Jake:哈哈哈大卖卖
Jake: Hahaha, big hit
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahaha
Tasha: 啊哈哈哈
Tasha: Ahahaha
Jake:点击百亿开源
Jake: Billion clicks open source
Shure: 希望点击百亿啊
Shure: Hope for a billion clicks
Tasha: 这不是开源开源产品吗
Tasha: Isn't this an open source product?
Jake:开源产品吗
Jake: An open source product?
Jake:卖卖卖
Jake: Sell, sell, sell
Katrina:  上万star
Katrina: Tens of thousands of stars
Jake:对上万star
Jake: Yes, tens of thousands of stars
Jake:这个可以
Jake: This is good
Jake:专业这个专业
Jake: Professional, this is professional
Shure: OK那我们stop recording
Shure: OK, let's stop recording
Tasha:stop
Tasha: Stop
Choiszt: 这个
Choiszt: This
Alice:老板有筷子吗
Alice: Boss, do you have chopsticks?
Jake:这是吗不是
Jake: Is this it or not?
Alice:你的筷子呢
Alice: Where are your chopsticks?
Choiszt: 哎吃的时候不录
Choiszt: Hey, don't record while eating.
Jake:十恶不露
Jake: That's a big no-no.
Katrina:  怕内个弄
Katrina: Afraid of messing up.
Choiszt: 那我就不用场记
Choiszt: Then I don't need to slate the scene.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:对你不用场景
Jake: Yeah, you don't need to slate the scene.
Alice: 那儿那儿还少的一双就内双给他
Alice: There's a pair missing over there, just give him that pair.
Shure: 有勺子吗
Shure: Do we have spoons?
Shure: 对咱没有勺子
Shure: Right, we don't have spoons.
Shure: 怎么把这个麻将舀出来呢
Shure: How are we supposed to scoop out the sesame paste?
Jake:咱有有点勺子
Jake: We have some spoons.
Katrina:  有内个外卖的勺子
Katrina: We have those takeout spoons.
Jake:有塑料勺子
Jake: We have plastic spoons.
Jake:会画吗哈哈哈哈
Jake: Can you draw it? Hahaha.
Shure: 不会不会
Shure: No, no, I can't.
Katrina:  啊
Katrina: Ah.
Shure: 你这
Shure: You...
Tasha:哎什么时候断了刚断
Tasha: Hey, when did it cut off? Just now?
Jake:谢谢这是啥呀
Jake: Thanks, what is this?
Katrina:  麻酱
Katrina: Sesame paste.
Jake:我去
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Jake:自带美
Jake: It's naturally beautiful.
Katrina:  我这这么已经嗷我应该是内什么时候断了
Katrina: I already... Oh, when did it cut off?
Jake:嗯没关系没关系
Jake: Hmm, it's okay, it's okay.
Katrina:  素材已经录了
Katrina: The footage is already recorded.
Jake:对对对谢
Jake: Yeah, yeah, thanks.